I ran into an ex not Bobby
um looking my absolute
worst I think that's good for you and
and you know what you're not wrong the
worst is when you gain weight you mean
someone you see your ex-boyfriend like
ah
it's been crazy
right like you're like you know I did
that once with my high school ex this
was the last time I saw him and it was
right after college is that why he
locked you out he's like I don't want
her eating all of my Rice Krispies
treats and I had as as everyone who
knows me knows I put on a lot of weight
my freshman year of college new girl was
that when you're on new girl she was a
new girl
and I remember saw him I literally told
the classic lie I can't believe I did
thyroid problem no I said this for a
role